hey everyone welcome to this next
episode of yes you know what it is your
daily equation and today I'm going to
take up the question of what drove the
Big Bang what what baned what is
responsible for the outward swelling of
space that we currently witness now let
me put this in a little bit of
historical context covering some ground
that I have discussed in some previous
episodes but I like these conversations
one-way conversation though it's not one
way I look at your comments I do and
sometimes you see that I respond to them
so I like these conversations to be as
self-contained as they can be can't be
fully self-contained let me just give a
little bit of background that I've
covered before okay so as you know and
as we've seen back in around the 1920s
or so Alexander Friedmann actually bring
them up here at Alexander Friedmann
George Lemaitre they used in Stein's
newly minted description of the force of
gravity his general theory of relativity
to come to a conclusion about the
universe and to simplify slightly they
both pretty much recognized that the
universe should be swelling it should be
expanding Einstein himself resisted this
idea until the astronomical observations
not not that he made this might suggest
that Einstein was actually at the
telescope this is a visit that Einstein
took I think to Mount Wilson Observatory
with Edwin Hubble
so Hubble's observations of the distant
galaxies showed that they are all racing
away and at that point
Einstein changed his perspective from
the older view that the universe was
fixed eternal unchanging on the largest
of scales and took on this perspective
that the universe is expanding I think I
think was in this visit not to digress
that Einstein and Elsa is his wife /
cousin they were visiting Mount Wilson
Observatory
and I also got to talking to some of the
astronomers there and asked them what
they do and they described how they have
all this fancy equipment to understand
the universe its properties and its
history and so forth and Elsa apparently
responded by saying oh my husband does
that on the back of an envelope so yeah
that's a that's a that's the kind of
support that you need absolutely so so
anyway so this is the situation in 1929
Einstein agrees with the observations
and in fact with the prediction of his
own equations that the universe should
be expanding hmm sorry now this leaves
open an important question and that's
the question for today which is okay the
universe is expanding but what drove the
expansion to start what sparked the Big
Bang there must have been some kind of
outward pushing force that started
everything rushing out with space and
time themselves as well swelling what
what force could that be now Einstein's
own equations are basically silent on
this question because if you take on
Stein's math and run it all the way back
to time zero use the math to wind that
cosmic film back to the beginning mmm
sorry mmm I'm flunking the equations
break down if I break down it's
basically you get things equivalent to
dividing by zero you know that that in
any calculator computer whatever
dividing by zero doesn't make sense and
you get that kind of a so-called
singularity in Einstein's equations yeah
bringing everything here today so so
that's the issue Einstein's math itself
doesn't give you the answer so this was
puzzling and people thought about this
for a long time and I'm now going to
describe one potential answers not the
only answer for the history of the
universe leading up to the form that we
witnessed today but certainly is
a version of the story that many people
take quite seriously and have taken
seriously for many decades and that is
so-called inflationary cosmology just
let me just switch over to my iPad good
so what we're talking about as I said is
what banged you know what drove the Big
Bang and the answer that I'm going to
focus attention on is this idea of
cosmic inflation and I should say that
the originators of this idea Alan Guth
started it all off andrei linde a
important vital contributions Paul
Steinhardt and Android's Albrecht as
well very important contributions not
all of them agree on whether this is the
right way of talking about cosmology
today at the very end I'll mention how
certainly Paul Steinhardt has become a
critic of the very approach that he was
instrumental in founding but that's kind
of the beauty the beauty of science
right people don't walk in lockstep it's
not that there is some kind of
pronouncement from on high the priests
of physics declare how the universe was
no people look out at the data they look
at the equations and sometimes even
they're a very perspective that they had
at one moment in time can change and and
that's the beauty of the way we follow
this zigzagging path toward truth when
we're talking about the kind of truth
that science and physics in particular
can reveal ok so so what is cosmic
inflation and the idea is pretty
straightforward and it makes use of the
critical equation of cosmology that I
discussed in a previous episode but
again to be self-contained I will remind
you of that equation so if you define
something called the scale factor a
tea and what the scale factor is it
tells you the distance between two
objects let's say two galaxies but you
often use galaxies as the the tracers of
the size of space so imagine that we
have a couple of galaxies completely
arbitrary shapes but imagine that at
some initial time they are a distance
and I'm going to write this a little bit
differently imagine it's some initial
time there a distance d0 apart the idea
is that the scale factor which can talk
about the overall stretching of space it
stretches all distances by the factor a
of T so at time T then the separation
between the two galaxies will be a of T
times D zero why do we call it the scale
factor again you could imagine that this
is all sitting inside a kind of
schematic map of space a map of the
universe and then you know on any map
there is this thing called the legend
where you indicate how to go from
distances on the map to real distances
in the real world and imagine that
there's an a of T in that legend where
that is a scaling factor which says hey
you know one inch or one centimeter
may have been one Lightyear if there's a
big map at time initial time TI but at a
later time you now are going to multiply
that scaling by a of T so now one
centimeter or one inch baby a of T times
one light-year so it's the basically
this kind of stretching of the distances
given by how a of T say grows if it's
growing in time now what we want to have
therefore is an equation for a of T to
know how it changes in time and this is
what I discussed in an earlier episode
I'm just going to write down the
equation that emerges from Einsteins
field equations of the general theory of
relativity and they're a couple
of equations that are relevant but the
one that really will be most potent for
us today is this one D - a DT squared
divided by a equals minus 4 pi G times
now I'm gonna 4 PI G over 3 times Rho
plus 3 PS really 3 P over C squared then
I'm going to set C equal to 1 so Rho
here is the energy density this guy over
here P is the pressure and so if you
know the material that's within a region
of space and you're able to calculate
how much energy it has how much pressure
it exerts that allows you to write down
the right-hand side of this equation and
then you just have this fairly simple
differential equation to solve and this
will give you the scale factors say as a
as a function of time
now one thing somebody asked me about
this such a quickly say it now a here
again is scale fact there's something
slightly confusing because this term
over here D - a DT squared that's how
the scale factor is accelerating like D
2 F DT squared is acceleration but a
itself is not acceleration a is the
scale factor so just don't get those too
confusing for most of you didn't all
right so this is the key equation what
do we do with this
well the essential point is this if the
right hand side of this equation namely
Rho plus 3 P if that happened to be
negative if that happened to be negative
then that negative sign together with
this negative sign we dealed a positive
sign on the right hand side which would
mean that the acceleration of the scale
factor would be positive and that's the
kind of thing we're looking for right if
you're looking for a
you kind of want to start with some
small size right you wanted to rapidly
swell so you're going from the scale
factor say not growing perhaps initially
it's one possibility and then it's
rapidly growing so that's a rapid
acceleration and that's the kind of
thing that you want now you can have
that in this theory because although
energy density this guy is positive as I
discussed in a previous episode pressure
can be negative and negative pressure
simply means pressure that's not pushing
outward like gas and a balloon or gas in
a room but rather pressure that pulls in
where it's sort of like a stretched
rubber sheet or a stretched rubber band
wants to pull inward there's sort of
tension there so any substance that does
that is something that can source on the
right-hand side of this equation an
amount of ropa 3p that will drive say a
rapid swelling of space and accelerating
change in the scale factor okay then so
what's the idea well I noted in again in
previous episode again just to be
complete here that Einstein's own
cosmological constant is one example of
a thing a substance or at least a
quality of space however you want to
think about it
in which row plus 3 P is negative
because for it it turns out I haven't
explained this part and at some point I
will you can't sort of do everything in
a short period of time but P equals
minus Rho for this cosmological constant
this is therefore a constant energy
density spread throughout space whose
pressure is - that energy density and
then if you put P equals minus Rho in
the expression Rho plus 3 P of course
then you do get a negative number in
this particular case it gets a minus 2
Rho and that does drive an outward
swelling now the problem with a
cosmological constant is it's constant
for a big bang we don't want a constant
bang if you will we want it to just be
something that lasts for a short period
of time makes the universe big and then
we live through the aftermath of that
initial rapid rapid swelling the
cosmological constant is constant it
doesn't do that so we want something
that depends upon time and the answer
for that substance that might play that
role comes from the physicists I
mentioned before and it makes use of a
subject that we at some point may talk
about quantum field theory but it uses
the most basic qualities of quantum
field theory so it's not something that
will take us too far afield for me to
quickly describe what does it feel well
let me just give it a name
conventionally we usually call the field
Phi it's usually in this set up called
the in photon field you are familiar
with other fields of course like the
electromagnetic field what is that that
is a quality of space if you will that
at every location the electromagnetic
field in space gives you a magnitude and
a direction for the electric field and
for the magnetic field now the field
that we're talking about here is a
so-called scalar field so it doesn't
have direction it just has a value at
every location in space I the analogy
that people often use is temperature you
can talk about the temperature at every
location in space it can slowly vary of
course from location to location a field
is kind of like that it is a substance
that has a magnitude for a scalar field
at every location in space and you can
write down the properties of this field
you can write down what its energy looks
like and what its pressure looks like
let me just record those equations so
the energy associated with the field
well it has parts that depend on how the
field is varying in space how the field
is varying in
and also the potential energy that the
field has so oftentimes maybe I should
just draw a little picture of that first
oftentimes we have some potential energy
function please write thank you very
much
so if this is the value of the field and
this is the potential there are various
shapes that you can draw you know
something like this and that tells you
if the value of the field is given by
this number over here oh call Phi zero
then the potential energy is V of Phi
zero and there's no god-given maybe
that's not the right word there's no way
that we currently know of to determine
the potential of a field from first
principles we choose the potential curve
for a field in order that it performs
whatever function we needed to perform
in our theory so you should bear that in
the back of your mind but the point is
if the field has a potential function
given by V then its energy comes from
say three sources how the field changes
in time right as a field is rapidly
oscillating it has more energy that
emits not rapidly oscillating plus how
the field changes in space if the space
if the field is varying from location to
location there's an energy associated
with the desire in some sense of the
field to have a constant value so
gradients changes in the fields value
across space contributes energy as well
as this potential energy function and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
assume that we have a field whose value
across space is constant so I'm not
going to consider this contribution here
but I will allow it to change in time
because as I mentioned that's the whole
point of not using a cosmological
constant we want the fields value to
change in time so that I can source
perhaps a rapid swelling of space in
there
the universe and then it shuts off so
how would we do that so let me write it
down so the form typically is D Phi DT
squared plus V of Phi now this first
term 1/2 D Phi DT squared that she kind
of makes sense because if you think of
Phi is X then the X to T's velocity so D
Phi DT is like the velocity of the field
it's how quickly the fields values
changing in classical mechanics the
kinetic energy is proportional to 1/2 V
squared one-half MV squared so we have
1/2 V sub I squared and that therefore
the first term makes sense the second
term I've already described good what
about what about the pressure if you're
talking about pressure how does that go
and this by the way this is really
energy density I'm talking about energy
but you'd have to integrate this over
all space so this is really this guy
that we called Rho cool so what about
well say cool I use the e for energy but
it's really energy in a given volume of
space that's what I mean by calling that
Rho what about pressure well you can
also write down an equation for pressure
it's a little more involved to derive
that equation you get it from the stress
energy tensor T mu nu on the right hand
side of Einstein's equations I'm just
going to write down the answer for that
one which is very similar it's 1/2 D Phi
DT squared minus V of Phi that's the
only change the plus to the minus now
notice the following if D Phi DT is very
small and everything's relative here so
it's small compared to the value of V of
Phi of course then you will note that
Rho is very close to V of Phi P is very
close to minus V of Phi and therefore P
is very close to minus Rho that's good P
close to minus Rho means that in this
equation over here
we're in a very similar situation to
what we had over here which is a net
positive on the right-hand side of this
equation and that therefore can source a
rapid increase in the scale factor d8d
to ADT's group positive this is actually
exponential growth when you realize that
you have an a here in the bottom you
know if you solve the differential
equation D to a DT squared equals some
positive number times a then you know
that this would go like e to the square
root of that number T times some value
say at time 0 you take the first
derivative it brings down one square
root second derivative brings down a
second and therefore you solve the
differential equation so you've got
exponential growth if you have a nearly
constant value on the right-hand side of
this equation so that then is the basic
idea we just have to set things up so
that the rate of change of the field
respective time is really small how do
you do that well here's the idea that
historically first was written down by
Linda and also by starting heart and
Albrecht imagine that you have a
potential energy curve that has the
following shape it's really kind of flat
for a while and then it kind of
gradually rolls down to this value here
so this is the value of Phi now if you
think about the value of Phi as if it's
like a little ball when the ball is on
this hill it will slowly roll in this
direction but it won't have a high speed
so D Phi DT will not be big because the
gradient of the potential is so small
and then finally it will roll down more
quickly which means that in this region
over here you will have this exponential
exponential growth in scale factor a and
again that's just what we had right over
here the right hand side of the equation
is nearly constant because the 5bt is
nearly equal to zero it's nonzero but
it's much smaller than the value of the
potential and the value of the potential
here is not changing
hardly changing at all it's got such a
small slope to it so you get a nice
exponential growth in that period and
then in this section over here inflation
which is this is called I guess I didn't
use that language this inflationary
burst from the ad to ad T squared being
positive inflation is coming to an end
in this region because the Phi DT is now
becoming larger and therefore this
relation P equal minus Rho is being
violated and if you plug this in to the
right hand side of this equation
ultimately this will not be negative and
therefore you will not have the negative
times a negative giving you the positive
which is the rapid growth the
accelerated increase in the value of the
scale factor so then what is this idea
first of all this is called slow roll
inflation is just one example of
inflation but the idea is the bang in
the Big Bang is coming from right in
here this nearly constant value of the
in photon field in say some region of
space nearly constant across that region
nearly constant in time although it's
slowly decreasing that sources this
repulsive gravity right that's what this
is again this is repulsive gravity
coming from the fact that in this
equation over here this minus sign
together with this being negative
you'll the net positive and that gives
this guy rapidly growing outward pushing
so the outward pushing force is nothing
but the repulsive gravity sourced by a
nearly constant value of this in photon
field in a region of space across a
small interval of
time so here's where the bang happens
and then the field rolls down and
frankly I won't talk about it here but
it rolls down and some people write a
potential like this allowing this ball
to slosh up and down as it comes to rest
and as it sloshes up and down it can
actually produce particles
that's can where particles come from the
energy and platonic feelings down slosh
slosh slosh as it sloshes its energy is
drained by the production of particles
that ultimately are the particles that
make up you and me and everything else
so that's this basic idea of this
version of inflationary cosmology it
gives you a sense of where the bang in
the Big Bang comes from and let me just
show you a quick picture then so you
know I don't know just to make a little
bit dramatic so when the in photon field
is in this region over here here's what
happens you get this rapid swelling a
space it's rapid increase in the scale
factor ultimately rolls down allowing
particles to form that ultimately come
together under the more usual attractive
gravity yielding stars galaxies and all
the other structure in the universe now
can you test this idea well um kind of
what do I mean with that well here's the
idea what I just described to you is a
completely classical picture right balls
rolling down hills that's a very
classical notion you need to overlay
quantum mechanics on this picture and if
you do that you realize that when the
field is rolling down the hill its value
can actually slightly fluctuate at
different locations not enough to ruin
the analysis but it overlays slightly
different values of the in photon field
at different locations that then
translates into slightly different dyes
if the energy density slightly different
values of the duration that inflation
will last and when you take all that
into account it gives rise to slightly
different values of the temperature
across space that we should measure now
this is a so-called
temper
variations mi Sasha pees in the cosmic
microwave background radiation slightly
different temperatures coming from the
quantum overlay of jitters in the in
photon field as this process takes place
and then inflation kind of stretches
these little tiny tiny quantum
fluctuations it stretches them across
the sky so here is a picture of the
temperature variations across the sky
this the different colors represent
really tiny temperature variations on
the order say one part a hundred
thousand so it's kind of a torta force
to be able to measure these temperature
variations but here's my point the point
is you can do a statistical analysis on
how these temperatures temperature
values vary across the sky and then you
can compare it with a calculation which
overlays quantum effects on everything I
just told you today to get a prediction
for how the temperature should vary if
these ideas are correct and I'm now
going to show you a little graph that
shows you the mathematical prediction
from quantum effects overlaid on the
inflation of story that I just told you
together with the measurements and here
it goes that solid curve that's the
result of mathematical calculations
using inflation a cosmology and quantum
mechanics and the dots here are the
measured value of the temperature look
at that look at the spectacular
agreement between the measured value of
the temperature variations and the
predicted one coming out from this
inflationary story and and and look
that's that's remarkable right we
measured the temperature variations
through very sensitive telescopes that
capture photons that have been traveling
toward us since about 380,000 years
after the bank by measuring those
photons we can measure the temperature
of the region from which they emanated
and the slightly different values of the
temperature that we get give rise to the
dots on that curve and the dots agree
with a mathematical calculation done by
these little creatures crawling around
on planet Earth making use of some
mathematic
equations I mean wow it's kind of
mind-blowing so you might at that point
say done right we now have proof slam
dunk proof that we understand the bank
in the Big Bang that would probably well
certainly in my mind and in many
people's minds but not everybody I think
it's too quick
I am definitely one who has confidence
in this approach but I don't think it's
been proven why the criticisms and their
arm there's a there's a vigorous
argument if you feel that I'm hedging my
conversation right now it is I'm not
exactly sure how far into this
controversy I want to go but I'll talk
for a couple of minutes just to finish
up this episode and there is a
controversial happening right now
between those who think that
inflationary cosmology or some version
of inflationary cosmology is it we
understand at least not everything
between is in a great deal about what
happened in the early universe
I should perhaps say now how long oh let
me let me just bring my iPad back up on
the screen here sorry I should have said
this before how long is the duration of
time over which the value of the in
photon field is slowly changing so that
the inflationary expansion is happening
and it probably depends it completely
depends really on exactly the shape of
the potential energy curve that we write
down but as a rule of thumb let's say it
the expansion happens I don't know ten
to the minus thirty-three minus 32 minus
34 seconds the point is it's a really
tiny fraction of a second and in that
tiny fraction of a second the power of
the repulsive push is so enormous that
the universe can expand to larger than
the entire visible universe so this is a
truly bang I should have said that I
mean this is our rapid swelling of space
I showed you in the imagery but just so
you sort of see where it comes from in
the mathematics but I bring this point
up here because so much of the
conclusions
about what inflationary cosmology tells
you is dependent on what things were
actually like in the early universe for
instance we are assuming that there was
an important field or assuming that had
a potential of a particular shape right
we are therefore making some critical
assumptions about the initial conditions
in the early universe and that's the
main point people do not agree on what
the initial conditions of the early
universe were and until we truly
understand the initial conditions the
stuff that was there and the potential
any curves if that's relevant in
whatever theory that we're talking about
there's going to be significant
controversy and the contrary was a
little bit further in inflationary
cosmology because of one final point
which I'll now describe as the universe
rapidly swells the in photon field
continues to fill that region during the
inflationary expansion and that means
there's more and more in photon field if
you will attacked as the in photon
fields going under it's quantum
fluctuations it's quantum jitters let me
just come back here for half a second I
thought there's gonna be a short episode
don't you know me so as it's doing its
quantum jitters sometimes it's gonna get
her a little down but sometimes it
actually can jitter a little up hmm what
does that mean that means that it's
virtually impossible to ever fully use
the in photon field up so one region of
space rapidly swells for instance but
there's left over if you will in photon
field in the overall environment right
it's still filling space in some regions
it's gonna continue to roll down but in
some it'll actually jitter up and then
jitter down a little bit in general and
so forth so it doesn't simply all go
away and that means you can source other
big banks other rapidly swelling reasons
they will continue to undergo the rapid
swelling even if an hour reason
ultimately the in photon field rolls
down and that gives
to what's known as the inflationary
multiverse you know just sort of have a
picture of it in your mind here goes one
version so the empty table filled in our
little region sources our swelling but
the swelling continues in some sense he
got bank after bank after bank giving
rise to universe after universe after
universe and when you do the analysis
you find that in those other universes
say the cosmic microwave background
radiation that would arise from the
quantum jitters of the in photon field
in that universe could look very
different from the picture that I showed
you and yet the inflationary theory
would be able to explain that different
pattern of temperature variations across
the night sky in that universe so that's
a little disturbing because it kind of
says that it's hard to prove inflation
wrong because had the temperature
variations been different here we could
have explained it by saying well we're
just in one of those universes where the
quantum fluctuations just give rise to a
different spectrum of anisotropies now
the nice thing is that we don't have to
stand on our head carefully adjusting
the shape of the potential energy curve
to explain our observations in this
universe and that sense of Occam's razor
the simplicity of the potentials that at
least can come pretty close to
observations of those observations get
more and more refined we have to adjust
things more and more suggest to some
that inflation is just a non falsifiable
framework and this is a point that's
been made by paul steinhardt leading him
to introduce other approaches to
cosmology the bouncing cosmology that he
and his collaborators have put forward
and again as I said at the outset I
think it's great that there are
competing approaches my own view is that
inflation offers this wonderful package
that in a very simple mathematical
formalism is able to relatively easily
describe observations that we do make
here in this universe I'd be more
comfortable if we
could deal more fully with this
multiverse aspect of the theory not all
versions of inflation yield the
multiverse some of them look unnatural
in order to avoid the multiverse quality
so on and on the conversation will go
this should just give you a flavor that
it's an ongoing debate as to the status
of the inflationary theory within the
notion of fundamental descriptions of
the early universe and that's something
that hopefully observations may one day
settle for instance inflationary
cosmology naturally gives rise to
oscillations in the fabric of space-time
primordial gravitational waves if we
were to detect those that would be one
more piece of evidence in the
inflationary column and that would be a
wonderful development we thought we had
that some years ago it turned out that
the observations who are being
misinterpreted but that's that's the
nature of the game but the point of this
episode of your daily equation of course
is just to show you how very simple
mathematical equations can give rise to
a burst of repulsive gravity in the
early universe and that burst of
repulsive gravity is potentially the
bang in the Big Bang all right that's it
for today we will take this up in our
next episode or take up something else
or take up something related until then
take care